hello everybody my name is markiplier
i'm here and it's actually night outside
now and i'm here alone
playing a scary game
with night vision this is about as dark
as i could possibly make this experience
i've usually played horror games with
lights on because when i film myself i
usually like to have pretty lighting i
don't have that right now i have nothing
i'm going to turn off the night vision
so you can get a glimpse of what the
actual illumination is
that's what it is
i can barely see myself
[Music]
this
is the mortuary assistant this is one of
those rare cases of horror game demo
getting a full release which is what
this is if you remember this game i
played a demo and it was very spooky
very spooky and well made covering a
rather unique scenario where you were a
mortuary assistant preparing bodies to
be
observed during the wait
and then buried but in the middle of the
night things go horribly horribly wrong
as they tend to do in these games it's
time
it's gonna be spooky i played bigfoot
with night vision and it was a
transformative experience it suddenly
became very different because i am in a
pitch black room playing a horror game
the only illumination on my face is
from my computer monitor
where the game is actually showing me
stuff really weird
so some stuff fell over that's not a big
deal no i know it wasn't even my fault
but he sent me home right after that
i've already seen this i'm gonna skip
things for now because i've already
played it and i remember the last time i
played it i spent way too long looking
at all the stuff in the room so i just
know that my keys are here somewhere if
i remember
and i need to find them
for some reason i feel the need to have
or be quieter
i know it's not absolutely necessary
but i am alone and it is dark so it's
the natural instinct okay
and on the way we go i don't know where
this is going to pick up and where the
demo is going to where the demo ended in
the last video that i played this i
don't know where that's going to end and
this is going to pick up but i haven't
have a feeling that it's going to get
pretty
close to ending exactly for picking up
exactly where it is so anything that
i've already seen uh lexi and if you
could please
um
kind of scoot forward unless there's new
spooks happening
all right i guess i'll head to the back
and get started i guess i will
i already have one of them i already
have one i i already have one of those
i do
hello
little spooky
hello
i rebecca
mr delver i need help someone's outside
the mortuary someone is oh someone is
i know you're scared
i'll unlock the door in a moment what
this is very sudden but listen to me we
have to start right away i'm sorry
i didn't know until it made itself known
this morning that it was here let alone
bound to you huh
i had no way of knowing the possession
look this isn't funny stop you need to
take this seriously
you need to act quickly this is insane
i'll just leave i'll just [ __ ] leave
you can't leave rebecca i i can't allow
that for you
or for others it's far too dangerous
what am i supposed to do then most
bodies i work with at night are fine
so we stay
calm
okay
we embalm file the paperwork
everything
treat it like a normal day staying
focused will help uh-huh i left some
things for you on the desk
i'll call again when you get to the
embalming room
no wait
what the [ __ ]
thank you that's insane it is a little
crazy usually my first instinct is to
leave just some hazing for the new girl
or something uh
just play along
and do your job
and do my job
you got it i'ma do my job i'm not sure
what my job is
besides embalming but that's some new
setup for this
interesting
so i think there's a key somewhere that
i can get into the
i think there's a key somewhere that i
can get into the next room i just got to
find it
oh 10 out of 10 immersion
very fun where is oh well that's handy
okay
well good for me
hello i'm [ __ ] quitting tomorrow
who does something like this ooh i don't
know some silly prankster hello
all right listen carefully i'm listening
look i'm sorry but this entire thing is
extremely unprofessional
if this is how you treat new hires i
don't think i can work for you this
isn't funny rebecca you don't have to
believe me but i hope you do before it's
too late
the only way to save yourself is to
banish the demon before you're too far
gone
to do that you will need to learn the
demon's name
bind it to its chosen body and burn it
in the retort
look
i know this is a lot to take in i wish i
could do more for you
i had years to learn what i know
you have hours hmm
i've recorded a number of cassettes to
instruct you in the hope that having a
physical object with a known message
will help you stay grounded
i won't be calling again
you can't trust the phones
anything can be manipulated
okay listen to the tapes
learn the demon's name
burn the correct body got it the most
important thing in the room is in that
cabinet uh-huh open it up
okay
i'm sorry
i'm sorry
this is insane this is insane
just be the professional one grab a body
and get started well i don't know i kind
of want to open up this cabinet because
it seems super important
oh very fun
all of whatever this is i'm getting back
to work no no no no i'm curious tools of
expulsion
aha process of possession
okay the night shift database uh a
computer program combining all my
findings into one reference point
whatever the database contains all the
information on the process of expulsion
the tools used and most importantly all
the markings of the known demonic names
if you ever forget what to do
replay these tapes or look it up in the
database
the collection of demonic names is the
most crucial piece to the puzzle
you will need this information
my id card is in my personal belongings
drawer on the back is the passcode to
access it use it
in the weather the what the personal
belongings drawer what does that even
mean huh
are you sure you don't want to listen to
all these tapes and uh
know how to do any of this
aha
interesting oh i don't know any of that
i would listen to it but uh i'm gonna
listen to it
to its chosen body and burned uh-huh the
three objects in this cabinet
are your tools
first
the clay tablet in the center
is called a mark
placing the smaller pieces in the
correct configuration will spell the
demon's name
second
the bottles on the top shelf are a
special reagent that will react to the
mark
add a bottle to the embalming mixture
during the process
when the mark is placed on the correct
body with the reagent inside it will
force the demon to become bound to it
pay attention to signs that you have
chosen correctly
they can be obvious
or
once you are certain the demon is bound
to its vessel
burn it
finally the pieces of paper on the right
are called letting strips
it must inscribe the sigils of its name
in our world to begin the evocation
you will need to uncover these sigils to
use them
hold a letting strip up while wandering
the mortuary
if it begins to smolder and burn you're
close
when the paper combusts the sigil has
been revealed somewhere in that area
they can be anywhere
so look on walls under objects inside
furniture
okay
use the night shift what do you mean
what do you mean what do you mean what
do you mean what do you mean what do you
mean that knowledge to create the mark
what do you mean
what do you mean add the reagent to the
embalming mixture
uncover the sigils
build the mark and place it on the body
did that just happen because there was a
sigil revealed somewhere or do i not
need to worry about any of that i'm
gonna close this door i'm just gonna
close that door oh that's no that's not
open
that's closed good
as it should be i don't know uh what all
that's about and i didn't take in any of
that information i'm gonna go get a body
and then i'm gonna start embalming it
that's fine
oh yeah
this is uh uh creepy
especially with the um the the whole
darkness thing
i don't like it guess i'll grab a body
brandy castillo
hi brandy
uh i need to get the whole thing don't i
don't i need to get this
journey okay
all right
[Music]
building yeah it's probably fine
lock me in here
scaring the [ __ ] out of me
uh-huh
[Music]
hello hello welcome
you're coming with me
this is fine how you doing
dead
i hope so i don't like the wiggly feet i
don't like i don't like the jiggle
physics i don't appreciate the jiggle
physics
all right let's check you out okay let's
do that
peek-a-boo
you know i'll just leave that closed
yeah just close that
that's fine i need the file right
brandy
brandy
okay clipboard used for forms and
keeping track of mortuary tasks at least
i can keep track of things
yes i can uh
oh
fine here
oh no
hello
boy oh hey brandy okay
nope nope new job i'm getting out of
here oh yeah that's a good idea i'm
gonna get out yeah i'm gonna get out of
here
new career
[ __ ] this yep
i agree
[Music]
oh why would you need
no i just
i'm just saying things
i
need to get back to work
it's fine
it's fine is it fine
what happens if i leave
i don't wanna i don't wanna i'm getting
in
[Laughter]
[ __ ] oh you're kidding me i can't
believe him
oh
that's not good what am i doing
this is
ridiculous i shouldn't be out here
it's my [ __ ] fault what is get back
to work
okay
i guess i'm gonna get back to work
gotta close that door don't wanna get uh
water in my car
yeah the choice
i'm stuck here [ __ ] uh-huh
coffee
nope okay ah brandy you still there good
great uh let me check those tussies
that's weird
uh clipboard
i don't even know what that was all
about am i supposed to make any
blemishes well i guess i got it
um
okay
hi brandy
you okay brandon
don't meet me brandy
don't mind me boy what's going on what's
with your face
oh okay yep don't mind me oh i hate it i
hate it i hate everything about it okay
well that's good uh enter the markings
on the computer you
got it
i am on it
we got bran oh
i just click right that's all i do
head contusion right shoulder contusion
right leg blemishes
done
oh did i not oh
you still there brandon i don't like
this
i need to file the copy up front
i can't hold anything else well
time to lose this
got it
great
good you stay right there brandy you
don't move a muscle
you don't move a muscle don't move a
muscle dear god don't move muscle
it's time to embalm
yep time to embalm
all good all good all good
um
embalming okay
wire jaw with needle
wire jaw shut with needle
should i do the whole
this thing
whoa
why
who did that
who's there
hello i'm brave
i don't remember closing that
who's there
who's there
anybody
anybody there
okay i think we're okay
i think we're all good
just holding the piece of paper up and
wandering around
all is good okay i'm gonna leave that um
open
okay what about the needle what was that
about a needle what is that what is this
uh troker that's not what i needed
uh needle injector i do need this okay
so needle injector and
the
setting needles okay good
yep
yep
yep
ah
good
keys
extra keys to the mortuary
oh that's useful
maybe
i don't like that smile i don't like
that smile raymond i really need a key
to the hatch outside cleaner is low and
you mentioned having some down there
before i know you don't trust anyone to
go down there but having a copy of the
key would make things a lot easier for
everyone
would it now
for who
uh setting needles
uh-huh
they are right there
next to the thing okay i'm gonna wire
your jaw shut now don't worry about a
thing i can't use that here okay
okay oh i
don't like that
oh boy
oh
oh
oh
huh
oh that
is fine
you
you
there we go oh there we go
all right
great
i trained for this for years
i'm definitely qualified insert eye caps
to keep eyes shut
yep
that's what we do next
just gonna
shoot
oh
nope i didn't couldn't put him i thought
i was gonna do some winking
[Music]
was that always open was that always
open was that always open it was open
because i left it open it was open
because i left it open it was open
because i left it open all right eyes
wide shut time
there we go
[Music]
getting sleepy
getting so
sore there you go
okay
all right mix embalming fluid
glutaraldehyde methanol humectant
formaldehyde
okie dokie
that's humectant
formaldehyde good
cavity fluid
methanol there we go i already have one
of those do i
oh i do
interesting
uh
glutaraldehyde where would that
be
[Music]
glutaraldehyde
okay
done
do i put any reagent in it i haven't
noticed anything from the leading strip
it hasn't been smoldering
so i'm guessing i'm fine
oh what
do i put reagent in
is that what i do
that's just what's written why not
done
make an incision in the carotid artery
and jugular vein okay
i can't use that here i can't are you
sure about that
what was the noise
i'm just gonna real quick
oh
okay use forceps and clamp tubing i
don't know where doobing is
you the forceps now you're a troker
it's just the lightning nothing scary
about that
and
[Music]
easy i need tube i need so much tube
someone moaning out there this is just
call me a big [ __ ] but uh playing in
pitch black darkness
real spooky where's the tubes and we got
tube here
and they found some tube tube tube
i really wish this wasn't open so i'm
gonna close it
i feel so much better
oh
all down there
engage pump and let's die
what hello you're not brand
why why did you why did i let you die
why did you die
hmm what was uh what was the deal there
you uh maybe that's your fault
hmm
i don't know
your fault is it
hey listen you need to sit down regret
every second with you
okay
hmm
well nothing going on there let me turn
on this pump
wow
[Applause]
okay that seems good
uh it's all coming back to me turn off
the pump remove the tubes close the
incision easy peasy
done like it ain't ever happened
just that simple all right fill an empty
iv reservoir bag with cavity fluid then
insert troker into the abdominal cavity
easy i need a reservoir bag that's that
okay fill it with troker fluid which i
think is
[Music]
you're right
[Music]
cavity fluid
right
troker
hello
must have been the wind must have been
the wind excuse me
let me just show you
ah there we go
i don't like that i can see it through
the skin that's
oh no let's not
hello
no visitors
i said no visitors
excuse me
there we go there we go
all good there
mix cleaners and bathroom closet create
tank cleaner all right bathroom closet
here i come
let's see flow clean
cleaner base
that's just tank cleaner
what do i need
i do it
i guess i have tank cleaner
hey there brandy
[Music]
all right
check all right let's get the yeah you
really didn't need to step up your
stance your stand your skin care
where did i see the moisturizer i know i
saw it somewhere humectant
i saw a moisturizer somewhere and let me
tell you brandi you need it uh
[Music]
why do i keep forgetting where
everything is why is it dark in there
it's not supposed to you're supposed to
be bright
oh old building
uh hi hey blah
no visitors
where did i see i know i saw
moisturizers somewhere here
i don't know i keep forgetting where
everything is it's almost like things
are distracting me
moisturizing wipe i can't hold anything
else really
really i can't use that here oh
all right let me give you
a little wipe
rub it rub a dub it up
now you're looking good flying solo
i can't read that
okie dokie then let me just uh air it
out oh that's not good
oh it was just a shadow i thought it was
something spooky well i don't need this
anymore
maybe i should just
all right brandy
oh well don't mind me just going to look
for some demonic markings of types
[Music]
don't let anything be behind me
papa
that's another job well done
who do we got next
[Music]
how you doing today i didn't get your
name but i'll get it later
you gotta love your job
that's why we have podcasts
to let the day go by
okey-dokey grant
carvalho
all right what happened to you grant
what uh oh you got booboo
all right boo boo over there
i'm not seeing nothing
how about uh here no nothing there
oh your arm don't look too good there
that's just how it is that's how you're
built
how about here
no nothing there
nothing there
interesting
oh here we go
nothing there either is that really all
of it
it says two of four oh on the back i bet
it's on the back
let's turn you there we go there and
there we go
all right grant don't worry i'll take
good care of you i've been trained
bless you i've been training for this
for years so don't worry about a thing
we got grant here age 36
a rash and a mole on the
right shoulder
confusion left arm left leg
contusion nope left leg contusion submit
interesting
all right grant
you got a fun last name grant i like
that that's real nice
wham all right let me just file some
paperwork real quick i'll be right back
with you grant
hey hey hey hey
[Music]
there we go
all right time to get that flapper
sealed
you're uh you love to talk don't you
grant don't worry i'll fix that right up
how
swam
bam womb
skadoosh
all right that's looking good all right
time for those peepers open wide boink
uh open wide boink open wide blink and
shoop and shoot
easy peasy
all right time for the yield embalming
fluid schwap and uh if i remember
humectant all right humectant
we got formaldehyde
wham we got
glutaraldehyde which is
not there
there we go
oh
this is fascinating what a wonderful
turn of events
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'm missing something
oh i am missing something hello
[Music]
okay
we're doing great i'm glad this is all
happening
am i missing something now i'm missing
something i'm missing something i gotta
get out of here i'm missing uh the quick
sprint away and
really oh
my heroin kit all right do i have a
clipboard for this as well is this uh
all right let's get out of here can't
party without the kit oh oh
god
oh wait a minute
oh this is uh
oh
hey
you did this to me i did this your fault
oh
hi
all right oh
just taking a little nap
what
was that
i'm thinking this uh this uh
body might be a little bit haunted
if i had to guess i think it is a little
haunted if i wave this around is this
gonna do anything for me
i'm letting the air out
oh it's
oh
oh
gosh oh
all right well i should start looking
for things huh um
hello
hello
anybody see any demonic symbols
brandy you uh see anything okay it went
cafouche right near the threshold
maybe on the other oh hey
i see you okay
am i supposed to remember that it looks
kind of like a z
with a t
a zt
a tizzy i'm gonna call that one the
tizzy so i spotted a tizzy do i do
anything about that
uh
that
no that the tizzy okay i saw that need
more leading paper thank you
i already i already
[Music]
oh okay we got the p
that is the p
not just a p it's the p
us backwards
but i don't see anything else here so
the p
i don't know if there's a specific order
i'm supposed to put these in
uh can i get another one of these
thank you
let there be
fire
no really
fire
no okay
fire no oh
hey grant i'm ready
that's what i thought
that's what old girl
oh god
all right well listen you're being a
little silly
you're being a little silly grant grant
dude
oh my god ah
the pee
if i go outside it's gonna do anything
everybody here
anybody out here
man if only i add some light
well i don't know where the light is in
here so i guess that's just going to
stay dark
well i got two of the symbols i'm
assuming that the other one's going to
pop up when i get further along
in the
mortuarizing
let me get the region in here because
i'm pretty sure that this one needs it
all right slam this in here and we're
good to go all right let me get the
scalpel
all right now i don't need that and i'm
gonna need this all right and then i'm
gonna need some pvc tubing
yep
all right
easy
oh that's not good i should back up a
step why why are we why are we like this
be let
let there be something
oof
i do not like playing this in the dark i
do not
i do not like playing this in the dark
okay let's get back to work here
and then
why are you like that
hello
hmm
okey-dokey
check
let me just
have a quick inspect oh my god oh my god
oh where's the light switch there it is
hello
good
hello
i wasn't closed before but all right
hello
hmm
all right no more leading okay i see
back to work turn off pump close tubes
uh incision close got it yoink you like
it never well i left a little bit of a
mark on that one okay all right fill an
empty reservoir bag with cavity fluid
uh empty back here
cavity fluid
here
got it
need my
troker
we're gonna
[Music]
adjust
that's it is that shot is that a shadow
moving is there a moving shadow is there
creeping moving shadows to the right
there is there creeping moving shadows i
believe there's
i'm gonna just take a second here
okay it was nothing it was just
fine
it's actually fine if you think about it
oh yeah there we go
all right i'm getting quick this uh i
need to tank clean
of course big important step very
important just gonna air this out a
little bit big important step here
yep and wham we got tank cleaner
that's good to know wow
if you scream at ghosts they go away
that's how you uh assert your dominance
on the demons
demons love to be dominated that's a
fact you can you can verify that google
it if you don't believe me
[Music]
then i need to apply moisturizer can i
do this first
while that's happening
you all be moisturized nah i can't do
anything out of order so uh was i
supposed to get some other names
was i supposed to get some other names
i feel like i might have been supposed
to get some other names
brandy
randy
oh
you getting impatient there don't worry
i'll
i'll be i'll be right with you
hey don't worry about that thing i'll be
right with you okay everybody
what is that
what is this
ah
that's that's good all right you're good
to go uh let's
air this out a bit first
[Music]
okay that seems good
all right let's go for a ride
clark
charlie
oh chance
chase
all right see you chris
[Applause]
okey-dokey
that's another job well done all right
who is this
uh benjamin ben
benny man
let's get you processed ben
add
a how are you on this fine day ben
okay
fine
it's actually a good thing
anybody uh
any demons in here okey dokey well time
to get to work i need to get you
inspected
how are you looking how you looking how
you cooking good looking benjamin janie
oh you got five uh nothing immediately
noticed oh that would okay well
oh my oh hey
ben
i'm sorry i must be i i gotta go i'll
see you around ben
later
i vaguely remember something about this
happening
interesting
thank you so much
i don't care about anything anymore i
don't want to be here
hopefully please
[Music]
well this is all very sad
um but i gotta get back to work my boss
is gonna kill me if i don't get this job
done
so uh
oh anti-depressants great
oh uh something's wrong with my
clipboard
hmm
oh can't take that medication i don't
have any food
all right i gotta go i gotta
i gotta go i gotta go i have to go
um
i gotta go so i'm going to go now
nope i missed something
interesting
so i can walk on the nothingness is that
is that what i'm learning oh
oh
hey
keys to the high risk wing
because that's what you want i go right
to the high risk wing
this is
a good idea
hi uh don't close that door you didn't
okay hello
i'm sitting here holding your coin right
now wondering if i'll ever have one of
my own what would the point even be even
if one day i'm sitting here holding my
own no matter how many years i printed
on it i would still have always have
yours in my other hand never changing
stuck forever it would always remind me
of the life i cut short while i keep
going i can't imagine it
my dad's necklace okay
my dad's sobriety queen okay
excuse me
there isn't a day i don't think about
you memories will flash into my mind
uninvited in a moment of bliss torn down
by unimaginable guilt nothing to give me
helps i still have your necklace it's
one of the few things they let me keep
in here i'm not sure i can handle having
it anymore though i'm giving it to
grandma when she visits next i want so
badly to have that piece of you with me
but i'm afraid of it i don't deserve it
he told me that when i was little i
would put it around your neck every
morning as a way to wake you up i guess
kids just like shiny things and annoying
their parents i don't really remember it
much i just remember you being annoyed
with me after the hundredth time but i
would give anything to put it around
your neck one last time
i see you wake up
well it's very sad but um i got
like i said i got a
body to embalm
so i gotta
you know i gotta
go
don't tell me there's something else i
missed in there is there okay
ah
well i mean we all die someday don't we
okay go hey
oh no
okay
well it's not good i don't
why did that happen
oh no
oh
oh
oh it's uh
i don't know about that nerd
yeah i left it oh god the doors open the
door i'm closing the door i'm closing
the
door
what are you gonna do now nerd
okay it's uh
sonic the hedgehog
all right i'm come for you i'm gonna get
you i'ma get you
it was closed
[Laughter]
fool
i'm going in
uh what's up
ben
i'm just gonna get another one of these
[Music]
seems uh all clear let me go put in the
sonic the hedgehog and uh
we'll be done
wham
i don't remember what to do about that
but i remember what to do about you it's
time to get the contusions looked at
how's your back
i see i see i see
okay
uh
there's that on the face
i can't look at your face apparently
all right why are you smiling stop
smiling i don't like to smile
i don't like the smile
maybe you had a glorious death
i feel like you can
die with a smile on your face um what's
wrong with your your fingies nothing
what's wrong with your tootsies nothing
yes something
what's wrong with your other fingies
oh
all right
well that'll do for that can you stop
smiling
i'll do something about that smile
all right
no oh i need to file the
hey
no visitors need to file the report
mole head
mole head
that's what they called you been
keratolysis how do you even know what
that is
mild abrasion right leg submit
oh such pleasant sounds
perfect i'll be right back ben if that
is your real name
okay time for the
the smile
[Music]
ah you're still smiling
stop it
all right
i don't like it
i don't like it
and the goopy juice
whatever this is it's going in
all right i got the scalpel i need the
tubing
let's do it
wham boom bam uh boom and then bam
hmm
huh
huh
what was that
what was that
oh no don't do that no that's not no
uh interesting
so what you're telling me
is
you're going to heaven
up
i get you
even if you're pointing down i
understand
um i'ma wave this around because it
makes me feel better
oh god no oh no
[Music]
oh good
oh hey uh
hi how you doing good to see you can i
help you okay well that's a brick wall i
don't know how you did that that's a
very moist brick wall but uh interesting
okay good
oh no
oh no
oh hey hi jesus
how you doing
hey you playing tricks on me ben
what are you doing
what are you doing
what are you doing
okay no flames
no flames maybe i should have listened
to that last tape maybe maybe that's a
thing i should have done
at every moment the demon is funneling
its energy through you
you are unable gross resist gross
identifying a demonic entity is a
delicate balance
the further you are from possession
the more time you have
the closer you are
the more the demon will make itself
known
allowing you the information to guess
its name
and the body it's bound to
the only way i've found to tell how far
along a possession is on your own
is to scribble on a piece of paper
don't think about it
just scribble
look carefully
if you notice anything strange
it's starting to take hold
there's a notepad and a pencil on the
desk
uh this seems like important information
time
i should have
i should have listened to that a long
time ago i should have i should have
listened to that a long time ago i
should have listened to that a long time
ago
uh-huh
where is it
i don't see it
uh-huh is penis
yeah i should have listened to that a
long time ago um
ooh
wait a minute is that the last symbol oh
god
is that the last symbol is there any
penis one
no
sure looks oh three i see three dots hmm
huh
well i seem fine
okay
how am i feeling okay good
let's do a quick loop-de-loop
i gotta be getting close but while
that's happening i'ma listen to tape two
must be bound to again chosen body and
burned
the three objects in this cabinet
are your tools
first
the clay tablet in the center
is called a mark
placing the smaller pieces in the
correct configuration will spell the
demon's name
second
oh hi oh my god oh my god
oh my
the god when the mark is placed on the
correct body with the reagent inside
it will force the demon to become bound
to it
pay attention to signs that you have
chosen correctly
they can be obvious
or extremely subtle
once you are certain the demon is bound
to its vessel
burn it
oh god these eyes on the right are
called
it must inscribe essentials of its name
in
when the paper combusts the sigil has
been revealed somewhere in that area
they can be anywhere
so look on walls under objects inside
furniture
anywhere
the demon will inscribe in sigils over
time to try and hide them so check
regularly
once you uncover the sigils use the
night shift database to decide which
demon you're dealing with
and use that knowledge to create the
mark
the steps are simple
add the reagent to the embalming mixture
uncover the sigils
build the mark and place it on the body
then when you're certain
burn it in the return
nice shift code i need to get the code
wasn't it on his
card or something
uh
1944 maybe
i don't remember what the code is
uh
oh i don't remember what the code is
he probably said but i or at least said
where it was
oh wait there's numbers
okay
[Music]
one of three for the houses
one three
one four maybe one three one four could
that be it
nah
oh hi
hey what's up don't mind me this is all
right okey-dokey
and that lights out again
great
how we doing everybody how are we doing
how we doing
oh if i can't get in the night shift
database i'm kind of boned aren't i
well i might be boned everybody i might
be boned i might be boned
oh my god stop it
that's my stuff you're throwing around
hey holes
all right i need a bag
yoink
there we go
there we go
[Music]
candy tank cleaner excuse me pardon me
pardon me
tank cleaner coming through
miss really
quickly listen to the third tape again
knows the second tape god
one the night shift database ah here we
go
combining all my findings into one
reference point my id card is in my
personal belongings drawer on the back
is the passcode to access it use it
got it okay how do i wrote oh
four two three three six four got it oh
nope
nope
nope
it really makes it hard to listen to
all right
this
working
yeah
this thing is huge
so uh
i guess
um this is david
raymond this feels insane but
i think you were right
this has happened a few times now but
let me see if i can
get in here
there it is
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
okay
so i need to look for the ones that are
moving uh ben here has been moving quite
a bit you know i gotta be honest
interesting
none of this is integral to banishment
but this knowledge may still be of use
i've found no particular religion has a
full understanding of the demonic while
bits and pieces remain true in various
interpretations there's much that is
inaccurate or simply unknown i've
compiled what i've found for various
archives and relics some words do not
have an entire equivalent which is
signified by n a
okay
okay that's fun
oh so they only have three
so i have the name then so i have the
name i don't know why but it's like
present the source that greased me out
i feel like i'm sitting still too long
so it must just be the three i must have
them
sigils of the covetous demons
oh no they got four oh god damn it
okay we got p we got sonic we got t we
got that that might be it maybe i just
gotta assume the last one you know what
i mean we got t sonic nope
not ain't it we're looking for something
with the p in it so i might be able to
guess the name
okay
i think it's this one
so t top sonic p and then double t
umbrella
okay
t sonic p umbrella that's it
i do believe that's it it must be right
it must be
all right i don't know what else to do i
think i have it but i'm not 100 sure
you gonna do anything
are you sure this is the right one
i am now
pretty sure this is you buddy i'm pretty
sure this is you
all right with that stupid smile on your
face
pretty sure that's you
well i'm gonna burn the [ __ ] out of you
oh my god
i'm gonna go burn you
oh my god
oh where am i what what is happening
well god where am i
what what
oh okay i'm gonna burn you i'm gonna
burn you yep i'ma burn you nope stop
looking at the goddamn thing i'm gonna
burn you i'm burning this one i
i don't care
demon
okay
i'm gonna burn you
i'm gonna burn you
are you sure
absolutely now now i definitely 100 am
yep goodbye
have fun being burned
[Music]
i don't know if that was the right one
but i'm pretty sure
oh
did i do it
there you are
good i did it
is it over
it's never over
but you survived
what do you mean can i leave
i want to go home you can leave
but once an entity finds you
all the houses of hell will do anything
to get back to you
i'm sorry
but it doesn't end here
from now on there is always a chance
this will happen again
no matter where you are
i don't want this
i just want to leave what do i do
i'm sorry but there's no going back
i've spent years learning everything i
can to keep these entities at bay
it's the only thing we can do
so what you're waging some selfless holy
war it's not a war
it's survival
and i'd hardly call it selfless
we're caught at the front line of
something larger but i don't do this for
some greater good
we either face it or fall to it
i wish i could claim to be someone
better
suffering hell to save us all
but i simply want to live another day
just like everyone else
when i first experienced this
i had to make a choice
i could run and spend the rest of my
days in fear
or i could learn to face it and keep
some semblance of a normal life
normal
right
it's not a life i would want for anyone
but choosing between a life of fear or
control
you're the first person i've met to face
this hell and survive
so i'm offering you a different kind of
job
work the night shift
learn what i know
give yourself a chance at a life beyond
fear
i don't know what you experienced but i
know it uses the worst parts of you
against yourself the more you experience
the more you'll confront the darkest
parts of your life
but through it
you'll become unbreakable
i'm offering the tools to take control
the choice is yours
i hope you come
back uh-huh i think i have to otherwise
i'm going to get possessified
[Music]
i guess i did it i'm the best
i'm the greatest
ever in the history
of mortuaising
which i think is the correct term
that was very good very creepy to play
in pitch black
it is
super spooky it just adds another little
layer of fear um i have an experience
like super creep out in horror games in
uh i mean a few war games here and there
will get me
super super spooked but
it's just like putting myself in the
scenario to play this so let me know
what you thought of this i mean it
doesn't make a lot of difference for you
guys it's just different coloring of my
face in the corner but for me
it changes things
it is weird
it is cool
and it is spooky
so let me know if you like it i might do
more horror games like this because
anything to get that
sense of something breathing down my
neck
or something breathing down your neck
maybe there's more to this than we know
but we survived today
and that
is good enough for me
so thank you so much for watching
look in the description for even more
scary games that i've played in the past
and uh just browse my channel for the
probably thousands of scary videos that
i have
subscribe for more
listen to distractible ending wonderful
any one of one of five ending one of
five shifts completed how many shifts
could i have possibly completed wait
what do you mean i thought the game was
over also yeah the seller i wasn't even
able to get in the cellar wait what was
any of that
if after playing this game you
experience abnormal happenings around
your home or have a certain changes in
behavior of yourself or loved ones reach
out immediately to your local church and
paranormal investigators
interesting
do any of you
feel some of that
do any of you
sense a change in your surroundings
do any of you feel uncomfortable where
you currently are
oh my god there's another shift
fascinating
so that's just total stats
i'll have to come back to this thank you
everybody so much for watching
and as always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]